はい まあそれで まあそれはもうそんなに難しくない
シークエンシャルな説明だからね
で それで二重で見た方がいいと
もうこれ単純な論理で言ってるんです
で それからもっと面白い説明があるんです
これはブッダゴス長老の説明です
どっちがいいかな ちょっとわからない
まあ これあの見とか で
まあ一応まだ説明つけてないんだけど
これセットがあります
こうやってセットがあります
こちらまたセットがあります
で それは過去 真ん中は現在
最後は将来未来 そこで過去にいる人が
まあ本当は結果は先に書かなきゃ
過去にいたということは
それ結果で見ると過去で因を作るんですね
過去に因を作ることによって現在の結果が生まれるんですね
現在の結果によって現在はまた因を作って過去で結果が作るんです
ですから 本当は因果ではなくて
カート・イン カート・インという風に書いた方がもっと正しいかもしれません
一応因果とかそんなふざけ方だから因果
因果とか言ってましたけどね
そこであの十二因縁の三
三世に分けたでしょ？三時に
それ三時の中で過去にあったのはAvijjaとサンカーラですね
無明と行があったんですね
過去生に 無明と行があったということは
この過去生の因です 過去生に生きてた人に無明があって
それで行があった で 同時にその人に渇愛があったんです
それで執着もあったんです
それでバラが生まれる
バラ・カルマですね 愚があるんですね
アビダンの場合はバーはあの
まあ一応合で見た方がいいんです
サンカーラも合で見た方が簡単ですけど
それはダブっちゃいますけど
そこで過去生でこの原因は 5つあるんです
原因 そこでAvijja
パッチア サンカーラ 明から行が生じて
行から識が生じるでしょ
そこで現在は生まれちゃうんですね
人が ヴィンニャーナ ヴィンニャーナ
パッチア ナーマ ルーパですね
ナウルーパからサナーヤタナが生まれる
サナーヤタナからファッサが生まれるんですね
ファッサからジュウが生まれるんですね
五つ これは現在 だから過去でこういう風な原因があって
無明があって 行があって
カッサヤがあって 執着があって
またウが 業が生まれる
あった それで人のその原因によって現在
ヴィンニャーナとナウルーパが生まれてきて
ナウルーパの先にサラード
ファッサ エーディナーナも生まれているという
これは因 これは果 ですから
これは果ですね この因の果
こちらなんです だからここをちょっと逆にした方が
逆にします その方が分かりやすいんですね
これはアーラハンで 同じですね
同じですね アーラハンとですですね
ですから あの こちら 過去世
過去世で因が五つあります
で こちらの果は書いてないんだけど
まあ一応分かりやすいんですね
過去世でも体がありましたからね
それは後で書きます それで現在もこの因によって果が生まれるんですね
ですから アーラハンで
また逆にします 最初は逆に書こうと思って
じゃあこういう風にしましょう
で 過去世の人にこういう
原因がありました 無明
行 渇愛 執着と有という原因がありました
それで一応業の塊になりますね
それで新しく生まれる色と名色が生まれてきて
それから六処が出てきて
それから触が出てきて
それから感じるようになる
この現在の人間です 人
この現在にいる人が渇愛があるんだから
また これ現在の人間であると思っちゃうと
この現在の人間がこれで終わらないで
あの霊的な十ありますから
また渇愛生まれるでしょ
渇愛からウパーダーナ生まれるでしょ
執着が ウパーダーナからバーヴァが生まれるんです
それも現在でしょ この八は現在だから
前回説明しましたからね
現在の人間にはもう色と名色と六処と触と十があります
その十から渇愛と執着と有が生まれるんです
それにこの現在の人間にもまだまだあるんです
無明と ありちゃあとサンサーラがあるんです
これは十二のリストにないんですけど
一応足してみるんですね
なぜ足してみるかというと
あるんだから足してみるんです
それが大体わかるでしょうね
これで現在の人間なんですね
そこで現在に生きている人が過去生から持ってきた禍があって
それで終わらないで因作ってるんですね
この因によって来世の果が生まれるんですね
バーヴァの次にジャーティでしょ
ジャーティとジャラーマラナ
で ジャーティとジャラーマラナと言ってもよろしいし
ヴィンニャーナ ナーマルーパ
サラーヤタナ ファスタ
ウェーダナーと言ってもよろしいし
このジャーティっていうのは生まれる決勝因だからヴィンニャーナなんですね
まあジャラーマラナはまあちょっと置いておかなきゃいけないんだけど
一応経典のリストでジャラーマラナありますからね
それは別にしておいて
別にしておいて その中に何があるかというと
ヴィンニャーナ ナーマルーパ
サラーヤタナ ファスタ
ウェーダナー で この一つ
カですね これ将来のカ
その将来のこのカがあると
その人は次に何をやってます？タンナー
ウパーダーナ サヴィジャ
サンカーラここにあるでしょう
そこでまた十二を見てみましょう
過去生でアヴィッジャー
サンカーラがあって 来世で現在でヴィンニャーナ
ナーマルーパ サラーヤタナ
ファスタ ウェーダナー
タンナー ウパーダーナ
バーヴァ そこまで経典の十二ですね
それで経典の十二次にジャーティ
ジャラーマラナ将来に行っちゃうんです
一応経典の順番 じゃあ一応線引いておきます
これは経典の順番  [紙をひるがえす音]この順番は前説明しましたね
それで次の面白い説明というのは
例えば過去世でアヴィッジャとサンカーラ
無明と行があるということは
渇愛も執着も愚もあるということですよ
それで現在生まれるということは
ヴィンニャーナ 識が生まれて
名色が生れて 六処が生まれて
触が生れて 受が生れることや
そこで受まであると 当然ながら渇愛があって
執着があって 愚がありますと
渇愛 渇愛 渇愛 執着 愚があるということは
無明も行もあるということです
そこでこれは現在の因だから
来世で経典だったらジャーティ
ジャランガラという二つなんですけど
はっきり言うと ケッショ
ヴィンニャーナとナーマ・ルーパとサラーヤタ
パッサビカーラ 色と名色と六処と触と受が生まれるんです
そこで来世でその人に受があるんだったら
次に当然またタンハー
ウパーダーナ アヴィッジャ
サンカーラ アヴィッジャ
サンカーラなどがそこにあるんですね
来世の人の体の中に 来世の人の体の中にこのセットありますから
また再来世で 再来世でいいんですか
じゃあ次に また同じセットが現れちゃうんです
それで理解しやすいよう少しまとめてみます
過去で原因五つすと将来結果が出すと
将来原因は五つすと 間違えた
過去世で原因 原因五つすと現在結果が五つすだよと
現在原因五つすで将来結果が五つすだよ
だから一応輪廻はそれでわかりますね
輪廻の説明は そういうわけで輪廻していくんだと
それで過去の原因五つすというと
お釈迦様はそういうふうにおっしゃっているのではなくて
論理的に五つす作ってるんですね
それで現在の結果が五つす
それは経典の通りに そこで結果が五つす
原因は五つすという場合は三すしか経典にはないんだけど
その二つは論理的に入れてある
それでも二重が成り立つんですね
そちら十と五と五と 二重が成り立って
あの 結ぶ部分が二つありますね
いわゆる三つの項目 過去現在未来という三つの項目を二つのところで結んでいるんですね
この 九番目  二百四十ページの九番目ですね
説明しているのはこれ
これなんですね どうですかね
わかりましたね だから私たちはいつでもセットでいるんですね
結果であって 原因も持ってますね
その原因の結果は その原因の結果は次に作っちゃうんですね
ですから 因果というよりは
よりは 果と因 果と因の流れなんですね
だから因果で見ると そこを止まっちゃうんですね
だから因果で見ないで
果因で 果因で見るんです
で まあもっと分かりやすくすれば
今私 ここにいる私が結果でありますね
その結果自体が因でもありますね
だからさらに新しい結果が作っちゃうんですね
作った新しい結果はまた同時に因でもあります
ということで 果と因というのはまた離れないものになってしまっちゃうんです
一応それでまあ終わると思いますけど
因果法則は だからこのブドウ長老やらね
アビダルマでそうした面白いところは
普通の人々 我々は原因と結果で物事を考えちゃうんですね
この原因でこの結果だよと
こちらでは逆に結果と原因
この結果があって その結果が次の原因を作るんだという風に
この背向くようにしちゃうんですね
背合わせで いわゆる体が
果が因になりますと 果が因になりますということ
だからこちら過去世の人間には無明が業がいろいろあったということは
その人にもはっきりした体があったということだからね
その体はもっと前の原因の結果なんですよ
そこでこの十二番目に行きますが
十二番目ムーラという根本という言葉使ってあります
この十二のセット あるいはこちらで書いているような二重のセットを見ると
その中で一番大事に考えてほしい二つあるんだと
根本的な二つ それは無明とアヴィッチャーとタンハーですね
この二つは一応根本で輪廻の根本だと
アヴィッチャー 無明 渇愛はタンハー
その中でも大変この我々の輪廻転生というか
苦しみの一番元の原因として何か探すと無明と渇愛ですよ
そう言ってるのは お釈迦様そうおっしゃっているんですね
なぜ人々は終わりなく輪廻転生しているかというと
アヴィッジャとカッサヤだから
それでなんでその だからその二つを何とかしなくちゃいけない
目を消しても意味がない
耳を消しても意味がない
面白いものを見ると私に欲が生まれるんだから
面白いものを全部消してやったっても
心の問題は解決したわけではないんですね
嫌なものを見ると怒りがいるんだからといって
嫌なものを消してやったっても意味がないんですね
ですから 我々は何を消すかというと
無明と渇愛を消すんだと
それは消せますかというと
いつでもあるんだから消せるんですね
過去でもあったし 今もあるし
これからもあるし まあとにかくこのセット見ても常にもあるということわかるでしょう
だからそれはこういうふうに説明してだっても
このアビダンマの人々にも経典からまるっきり離れることは不可能だから
経典を明確に説明するのアビダンマの仕事だから
だからお釈迦様は一応こんなものをにも不可分な相互依存的な相対的な成り立つ一つのセットということでしたから
だからアヴィッジャ パッチヤサンカーラというふうにおっしゃいましたから
やっぱりそれはその中にもその説明は入ってるんですね
ですから 現在我々の現在のことを見ても
すべてがありますね アヴィッジャサンカーラ全部
これで生老病死もあるでしょうに
現在も 将来にしても同じことで
過去にしても同じことで
いつでももありますということ
だからなかなかこのシーケンシャルで説明するのは難しいね
これはすごい無理やりにシーケンシャルの説明なんですね
その方が分かりやすいんですけど
だから例はないんだけどね
心の問題だから 物質的なことでしか例は出てきませんだからね
例えば細胞から細胞生まれるでしょ
原因と結果の中で何か差がありますかね
今生まれている細胞が前の細胞で生まれているんですね
だから原因も結果もイコールでしょうに
DNA から DNA が生まれることだからね
だから DNA というのは螺旋であるでしょうに
それはそれはすごい そこ物質を見ても
それ DNA もやっぱり生命として心のエネルギーで成り立つものだからね
そちらはやっぱり螺旋にできていて
それは細胞分裂する はこの二重が割れちゃうんですね
割れたところで一部欠けてるんですからね
二つで成り立たなく 二つでつなげてるんだから
一つこれ二つに割れてしまい
二つで原因と結果で二つで割れてるでできてるんだから
それ割れちゃいます 簡単に
割れたところで一つ一つ原因になっちゃうんです
なって割れたものと同じ DNA をつなげてもらっちゃうんです
アミノ酸をつなげてもらっちゃうんです
それで新しい細胞 二つが生まれますけど
結局前の細胞と全く同じ
だから鶏 卵から鶏が生まれるということは唯物論ではありません
それだったら細胞の分裂を説明できなくなりますからね
だから そういうふうに考えちゃうと
卵先か鶏先かっていう問題が出てくるんですね
なぜならば全く違うものだから
卵とヒヨコっていうのは全く違うものだから
それは人間の目で見える変化であって
じゃあ細胞から見れば卵の時の細胞に当たるのか
全く同じでしょ 別に大した変わったことじゃないんです
ただ一つ割れたところで原因が二つになっただけ
一つの結果が原因二つになりますね
例えば細胞一個が原因でしょう
その中にある DNA が割れたところで原因でしょ
それは 今まで結果であったものは原因になってしまったんですね
で 面白いことは ここで原因二つになったんだから
どうせ結果が二つになります
それで一個の細胞なんですけど
卵の中にあるのは それは二つに四つになっていく
そういうわけで もうヒヨコも出てきて
鶏も出てくることは可能ですし
だからしっかりしたAからB B
からCということではないんですね
だからはっきりと卵からヒヨコが生まれるわけじゃないんですね
卵からは日光の細胞は生まれます
ヒヨコは生まれません
日光の細胞から四つ生まれるんであって
四つから八つ生まれるんであって
そうやって細胞を増やしていくんですね
それで卵というのは単なる殻だけですからね
そういうふうに考えちゃうと
それと鶏には関係ないんですね
だから大きくなりましたから
それは破るだけ 卵が割れる前に
その中にヒヨコがちゃんといるんだから
そこで小料病死とかなんとか変化とか
どのように説明するかというと
もし増える一方だったら
我々もこの何て言いますか
恐竜みたいに大きくなる一方ですね
恐竜の細胞にはそんなちょっとプログラム
プログラム ちょっとなかったみたいです
その減るプログラムが
だから恐竜生まれる時はほんの小さいんです
今のトカゲの子供と同じく小さいんです
あのブロントサウルスにしても
恐竜の卵だから巨大な卵ではなかったんです
今化石あるでしょ？卵は普通の卵なんです
すごい大きなブロントサウルスですけど
これ卵これぐらいなんです
それ食べては増えて大きくなって大きくなって大きくなって
細胞はもう分裂して分裂して
ずーっと大きくなっていく
そこで恐竜みたいな巨大な体になる
で なんで我々の体がそれほど
ある一時期はすーっと大きくなりますけど
ある一時期はそうならないかというと
この今も細胞分裂はありますけどね
ある細胞が原因作らないでそのまま死んじゃうんですね
例えば八個の細胞が十六個になるでしょうし
十六個の中で六個ぐらいもう分裂しないでそのまま死んじゃうんですね
残っているのは二重なんですね
二重で四重ができちゃうし
その四重の中で 例えば十
もう三十個ぐらいそのまま死ぬと
で 残りがまた割れるということなんです
そういうことで 我々の体の大きさが
まあある一時期で止まってしまう
そういうのは自然法則で
まあ生き延びたいという欲望がずっとあるんだから
生き延びるためには何でもする
だからこの大きくなるだけはノーじゃないんですね
もし人間も恐竜みたいにずっと大きくなるだけだったら
生き延びることは不可能なんですね
体がどんどん巨大化 巨大化になってきて死ぬんです
栄養 大きい もうどんどん大量に部品入れないと
新しい細胞のため DNA
初めはほんのちょっと二
三グラム食べた方が食べてよかったんだけど
どんどんそれは何キロになるでしょうね
それで今 今ゾウさん見たって
もう何トンも食べなくちゃいけないでしょうね
そこ部品がないんですね
だから早く死んじゃうんで
早くは死にたくないんだから
じゃあプログラム変えましょうと
細胞に死んでもらおうと
体の細胞に ということで
体の細胞に死んでもらう
それで宿主細胞で長生きすると
というプログラムになりましたからね
だから生き延びるために
これはもうダーウィンさんの論理も同じことを言ってますけど
私も 生き延びるためには
動物の体が大きくなるか小さくなるかと
クジラが大きくなってしまったんですね
なぜかでクジラは普通は攻撃的じゃない
誰とも戦わない 一番この非暴力主義者なんです
それだったら やっぱりスケールで勝負しなくちゃいけないんですね
で 大きくなっちゃうんです
陸上の動物の中でも一番親切な
誰にも目をかけない動物はゾウさんです
それでスケールで勝負しているんで
ゾウさんには誰も攻撃しません
なぜならば大きいんだから
ただそれだけ である動物は小さくなるんですね
だから我々の祖先というのはね
ものすごい小さかったでしょうね
恐竜がいた時は 哺乳類動物も出来上がってきて
ものすごい小さかったんです
恐竜は王様で ものすごく巨大化して偉そうにいたんだけど
で もう隠れてものすごい小さい
それで今の哺乳類動物は出ているんですから
そちらが支配しているんです
爬虫類は負けちゃったんですね
だからそれとこれとはまるっきり関係ない話ですけど
こちら心の流れのことを言ってますから
細胞っていうのは物質ですからね
細胞の変化もやっぱり因果法則にのっとってないといけないので
だから細胞の変化はこの十二因の変化
綺麗に説明できる 一つでも欠けたら細胞じゃないんです
[咳]DNA 一個でも取っちゃったらもう終わりです
決まってる数が全部なければいけません
染色体とかね もう取ったりすることはできません
いつでもセット全部あります
だからこの今の DNA の工学とかいろいろできてますけど
やっぱり人の体のどこからでも
どんな細胞から細胞を取っても
どんな人かでわかるでしょうし
だからこういう論理的には分かりますからね
だからこのスーパーマンの映画に一つありましたでしょう
スーパーマンの髪の毛一つ取って
ある人がもう一つスーパーマン作っちゃうんですね
髪の毛 1本だけ盗んで
それで DNA を取って
それで新しい人間を作ると
その人は全くスーパーマンなんですね
それでその人に心理的に教え込んで
もう悪人にする して スーパーマンと戦うようにすると
そういうふうなスーパーマンの映画シリーズありますからね
やっぱりこの大人の映画より子供の映画見た方が
まあなんとか役に立つんです
そちらにもやっぱり体が 100%同じですけど
そちらにそこにも心に教え込んだことによって人格が違うとよく話もあるんですね
100%同じ人なんですけど
やっぱり全く正反対の善人と悪人ですね
だからそちらは仏教の話も何も知らない
単なる子供騙しばっかりやってる世界で使ったけど
やっぱりそちらでもやっぱり心理から離れることは不可能なんです
だから普通の医学的な考え方で言えば
DNA は 100%同じだったら性格も 100%同じでしょということは論理ですけど
やっぱり映画の世界ではそうじゃなくて
もう違うことをその作った人は彼に教えてあげるんですね
一番悪いのはスーパーマンだと
あいつを殺さなくちゃいけないんだと
ああだこうだと教え込む
似てる人はジャータカ物語もあります
あの 全く似てるんです
で これオウムなんですけど
オウムと鳥 で 卵 2つ産むんですね
そこでヒヨコになったところで
この風が台風が来て あの巣が木が壊れておりちゃうんですね
折れたところで このヒヨコ 2羽がバラバラに飛んでいっちゃう
1羽がこの泥棒のところに落ちるんですね
山の上 もう一羽が修行している行者がいる
あの くちがあって そちらの前に落ちたんですね
風で 泥棒たち見たら小さな鳥だからね
飼って育てたんです この行者たちも自分の前に落ちた鳥だから
もう飼って育てたんです
そこである日 この国の王様が狩りに行って迷子になっちゃうんです
迷子になってもう水もなくて
あっちこっち行くと なんか人が住んでるようなところを見て
そこに行ったんですね
助け求めて 行ったら誰も人がいないんです
そこでオウムがいるんですね
いて すごい厳しい言葉でこいつを捕まえろ
縛っておこう 首を切ろうと
全部持っているものを全部奪おうとかね
という話するんですね
安けろ で その話を聞いたら
王様がすごくもう自分はそんなこと言われると
もう人がいないし もう安けろ
捕まりましょう 捕まえろと
全部財産を全部取りましょうとか
なんとか言うと 王様がすごく怖くなって逃げたんですね
怖くないと 逃げたってもやっぱり助け必要し
ご飯 水やら何か食べなくちゃいけないし
で もう一つの人が住んでるところに行ったら
そこにも人がいない はい
いらっしゃい よくおいでになりましたと
どうぞお座りになってくださいと
水やら食べ物ありますから
どうぞ召し上がってくださいとか
すごい丁寧にしゃべるんですね
この 2人もしゃべるのは 2人のオウムなんですね
オウムは一応人間の言葉を真似て喋りますからね
王様びっくりするんですね
で 安心してびっくりして
そのオウムにあいつはもう助け求めてもう一つのところに行ったんだけど
そんな話じゃなくて すっごい凶暴な恐ろしい言葉を喋ってたんだと
あなたはものすごい丁寧にもう私に接待せよしてるんだと
不思議だなと思ったら
そのオウムさんが ああ
そうですか おそらくあれ私の兄弟だと思いますよと
兄弟だと思いますよと
なんでそう思います？それはまあ
もう本当は私たちはもう